[Music]
Kanye West is down to smash all of wife
Kim Kardashian sisters
[Music]
seems like yay is on one dropping his
new song ecstasy over the weekend the
surprise release had everyone buzzing
after he opened the track with this
verse you got sick dogs I can bro
you gotta sister-in-law you'll smash I
got four for the song artwork Kanye
fittingly used to pick up the
kardashian-jenner ladies livin it up at
Kylie's 21st birthday and went on to
spit bars about his in-laws who are
famous for breaking the Internet please
welcome Kanye West while Kanye is known
for being outspoken the rapper was
recently left speechless when he
appeared on Jimmy Kimmel Live and talked
politics you so famously and so
powerfully said George Bush doesn't care
about black people it makes me wonder
what makes you think that Donald Trump
does or any people at all why don't we
take a break the 41 year old took to
Twitter to explain his reaction and shut
down critics quote I wasn't stumped I
wasn't given a chance to answer the
question
adding the question was so important I
took time to think and then I was hit
with the let's go to commercial break
that interview showed strong
personalities with different opinions
having a civil conversation
[Applause]
you